it's known as a secure training center
this is oak hill in milton keynes but in
effect it's a children's prison
where young offenders from the age of 12
to 17 are kept and they can be there
after conviction or even on remand but
some of them
could be there
having been convicted of the most
serious crimes now of course like all
prisons they are from time to time
subject
to
inspections and in the case of a
children's prison it's by
ofsted the education watchdog the
prisons inspectorate and also the care
quality commission so there's a lot of
concern
over the way these places are run but
this is a very damning report uh in the
last few days
on oak hill um and what's happened today
is that
uh the re the inspectors have written to
dominic
raab the uh the new justice secretary
demanding urgent action
in effect it's asking him i mean in
theory he has 28 days to reply but in
practice in the in a very similar case
another center like this was shut down
within 24 hours and all the children
taken out and dispersed elsewhere so
that's a possibility that something like
that could happen but what we've got
here is a damning report on oak hill it
talks about
widespread failings very high
use of force by staff
frequent violence
among
those young children and in some cases
recently
um on average children were being locked
in their rooms for
19 hours a day but in some cases that
went up to 23 hours a day and as i said
we're talking about children as young as
12 here um
the letter to dominic raab highlights a
lot of these concerns um talks about a
dilapidated environment um violence and
use of force and often inexperienced
staff but it says this as well
systems for safeguarding children are in
disarray senior leaders failed to ensure
that safeguarding concerns and
allegations are referred to statutory
agencies as required there is a
considerable backlog of safeguarding
concerns awaiting action
children therefore remain at risk of
serious harm
so that letter calling for urgent action
just gone in to dominique raab and we
wait to see his response